hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure oh Gott
nee hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwanne und willkommen zu einer neuen
Folge wie schmeckt heute backe ich die
Torte aus winsley Adams aus
Staffel 1 Folge 6 oh mein Gott diese von
ihren Highschool Freunden zum Geburtstag
bekommen sie wird in einem Grab
überrascht und diese Torte sieht ganz
toll aus sie ist schwarz und lassen
Sensenmann drauf und der hat eine Sense
in der Hand und in der anderen hat ein
Ballon ich habe jetzt schon Tränen in
den Augen und weil ich meine Torten
Skills von sallystortenwelt nicht erst
heute gelernt habe habe ich schon
gestern diesen tollen Tortenboden
vorbereitet und so wird er gemacht ich
habe meine weiße Schokolade genommen sie
klein gehackt und dann in einem
Wasserbad geschmolzen danach muss man
die weiche Butter mit dem Puderzucker
Vanilleextrakt und der farbpasste
miteinander verrühren anschließend jedes
eigelb einzeln für 30 Sekunden einrühren
und danach natürlich auch noch die
flüssige Schokolade rein in der
Zwischenzeit habe ich das Eiweiß mit dem
Salz zu Eischnee verrührt dann kam auch
noch der Zucker dazu und ich habe drei
bis vier Minuten weiter gerührt und nun
einfach das Mehl die Flüssigkeit und den
Eischnee im Wechsel kurz und mir den
Teig rühren wenn ihr so ein Glück habt
wie ich und zwei Bagger habt dann könnt
ihr auf die zwei backringe verteilen und
dann im vorgeheizten Backofen für 45 bis
50 Minuten backen sollte der Boden
eigentlich schwarz werden ja natürlich
aber aus irgendeinem Grund habe ich
gedacht wenn man ein bisschen schwarz in
eine große weiße Teigmasse rein macht
das dann auch der Boden schwarz wird
aber na klar der wurde halt grau das ist
womit bearbeiten ich finde grau passt
auch noch ganz toll in die Wednesday
Adams Farbpalette das ist leider noch
nicht der einzige Unfall der passiert
ist es gibt nämlich zu diesem Rezept
eine einzige Vorgabe die ich in dieser
Serie finden konnte außerhalb der Deko
die ja offici aussieht wie sie aussieht
und die man dann nachmachen muss und
zwar sagt der Bäcker Kaffee junge dass
er die Torte gemacht hat und
98 prozentige Schokolade verwendet hat
das habe ich bei meiner Ganache schon
auch gemacht und oh Wunder sie hat sich
anders verhalten und ich glaube das hier
alles ist Kakaobutter fett wenn wir es
abkratzen dann hoffe ich einfach dass es
da drunter eine gute Ganache ist und so
habe ich sie gemacht für die Ganache
habe ich Sahne in einen Topf gegeben und
habe die Sahne einmal aufkochen lassen
währenddessen habe ich meine
99%ige Schokolade klein gehackt und
reingegeben und wie ihr seht ist es
einfach nichts geworden das ist so
klumpig geworden und hat sich überhaupt
nicht verhalten wie
Zartbitterschokolade also habe ich noch
ein bisschen mehr Sahne hinzugefügt und
dann noch ein bisschen Zeit bitte
Schokolade und habe einfach nur gerührt
gerührt gerührt und aufs beste gehofft
und das Ergebnis ja bin ich heute morgen
vielleicht traurig aufgewacht und dachte
verdammt ich kann das nicht weitermachen
da ist einfach viel zu viel schief
gelaufen ja werde ich weiter kämpfen
natürlich ihr kennt mich ich gebe nicht
auf ich habe nur nicht vergessen wie
schwer es ist Tor zu machen so
wir heulen jetzt aber nicht wir machen
eine geile Buttercreme
170 Gramm Eiweiß Salz ganz schön viel
Zucker ganz schön viel Butter und noch
viel mehr Puderzucker Butter und zu wir
brauchen Zucker und Puderzucker wenn man
selber backt dann merkt man erst was
eigentlich so eine Torte beinhaltet ja
und das war's ich wollte so gerne Eiweiß
einfach aus dieser Flasche im Supermarkt
haben aber ich habe sie nirgendwo
gefunden das heißt wir müssen unser
Eiweiß selber pastorisieren und das
bedeutet dass wir die Keime im Eiweiß
abtöten denn wir kochen das Eiweiß nicht
das ist natürlich für so Bakterien
Salmonellen und so nicht so gut
hier machen wir jetzt unser Wasserbad
zum Eiweiß kommt jetzt noch Zucker und
die Prise Salz wie können wir die
vergessen das ist so viel Zucker im
Vergleich zum Eiweiß und jetzt unter
dauerhaften Rühren erhitzen damit es
bloß nicht klumpt denn Eiweiß kann hart
werden es sollte ungefähr 70 Grad haben
und ich habe so ein Temperatur Ding für
Wein 7 bis 10 Minuten soll ich jetzt
hier stehen und rühren das hat sich
aufgelöst und sieht jetzt so aus das ist
jetzt unsere Masse und die schlagen wir
jetzt auf 20 Minuten
20 Minuten später
der Eichen ist schon fertig das hier ist
Perfektion
führen wir die Butter für die
Buttercreme wir brauchen erstmal
Puderzucker wir haben ja noch nicht
genug Zucker und dazu kommt 250 Gramm
Butter
miteinander verrühren so sollte Butter
aussehen wenn sie fertig geschlagen ist
richtig schön weiß und cremig und jetzt
geben wir unsere Butter
zu unserer Schneemasse und verrühren
alles wieder wieder miteinander
hat sich da Aufwand gelohnt die ist
wirklich köstlich jetzt kommt endlich
der spaßige Teil jetzt ist alles
vorbereitet das kannst du lieber mal
erzählen dass sie zu hässlich aus ich
habe mir endlich so ein Teil gekauft um
Kuchen richtig zu schneiden
kannst
danke
seht ihr diese super schwarzen Kuchen
toll oder tolle Farbe
und das gleiche noch mal
so jetzt haben wir diese insane tolle
Buttercreme hier und hauen einfach mal
ordentlich drauf das ist richtig wie
Marshmallow Creme und dann werden wir
sie drauf gemacht haben vertan
einfach aus und easy und dann dreht sie
das nicht so WoW und jetzt machen wir
die Buttercreme drauf ist
was sind dafür action shots Deckel drauf
und fertig ist euer grabstein-torte ich
kann auch den Rest so an den Rand
schminken ich weiß nicht ob ich das darf
wahrscheinlich darf ich das nicht aber
wir scheißen darf so jetzt ist es
wichtig die erste Ganache ist schon
drauf zum ist der Kuchen dann gerade
überhaupt nicht ne oben kommt der hoch
so müssen jetzt erstmal diese oberste
Schicht wegkriegen ich hätte das mit dem
Dings nicht machen soll glaube ich das
war schon mal ein großer Fehler aber wir
gucken jetzt einfach mal wir nehmen uns
was von der schmeckt die eigentlich
boah man schmeckt 98% Schokolade ich
versuche gerade hier meine erste Schicht
danach drauf zu machen weil das ist die
wichtige also hier ist die Ganache Leute
noch mal für euch damit ihr das sehen
könnt hier ist die Torte da ist die Wand
sehen jetzt erstmal für 20 Minuten in
den Kühlschrank damit das richtig schön
fest wird und dann machen wir die zweite
Schicht danach drauf die erste Schicht
ist jetzt angehärtet und wir gehen
weiter mit einer zweiten Schicht sieht
doch schon mal besser aus ne sieht sie
gerade
also riecht auf jeden Fall von dust
wieder in den Kühlschrank wir sehen uns
wieder wenn die Ganache fertig ist oder
wir bleiben jetzt hier und jetzt
müssen wir das Fondant schon wieder in
Berlin
richtiger Kraftsport das ein Penis
heute klappen komm jetzt hier die Torte
hin und dann legen wir es drauf
ich habe so zwei glasfreier gekauft
damit ich so eine Torte glatt streichen
kann okay Leute den ganzen Tag so
schlecht gelaunt weil ich einfach
überfordert war mit dieser Torte aber es
wird
muss ich nur noch den verdammte unter
den Kuchen kriegen einen schönen
Abschluss hat das ist hier halt alles
noch so sehr nice das muss ich
vielleicht sauber machen aber jetzt
bevor der mir Umfeld packe ich den noch
mal im Kühlschrank
bekommen nun zur Königsdisziplinen
dieser Torte und zwar ist es der
Sensemann der Sensemann mit einem
Luftballon und einer Sichel in der Hand
auf jeden Fall
was Essstäbchen noch ganz gut ne und
dann kommt hier die Sichel dran
das ist unsere sichelmasse es ist nur
die Frage ich habe natürlich noch nie
eine sich
el gemacht oder damit wir unseren tollen
Mann Formen können brauchen wir eine
Modelliermasse und die beste
Modelliermasse die sich dafür eigentlich
eignet ist Rice Crispies mit Marshmallow
und dann kann man kneten 125g
Marshmallows 10 g Butter und 125g
und schmelzen sie gemeint Sam mit
unseren Marshmallows wir wollen auf
jeden Fall hier eine schöne
lecker lecker
jetzt schnell verrühren ich bin müde und
jetzt die Hände mit backtrennspray
Houston Problem
diese Nummer eins ist nämlich nicht
anpassen so Kühlschrank was hat
überhaupt nicht so funktioniert wie ich
dachte schon furchtbar der Sensenmann
auf dem Kuchen hält in einer Hand der
seine Sense und in der anderen die Hand
einen pinken Luftballon wo ihnen sagt
das ist ihr kleiner touch auf diesem
Kuchen und ich habe überlegt wie ich
diesen Luftballon nachmachen kann und
habe eine Styroporkugel gefunden die
eigentlich eine super Größe hat und eine
Büroklammer denn dieser Luftballon muss
ja nach oben fliegen und mit einer
Schnur würde er einfach nur noch unten
fallen deswegen nehme ich jetzt diese
Büroklammer biegt sie so auseinander und
dann hat man schon so eine Art
Luftballon Schnur auf der Torte hat das
so ein paar Kurven noch und dann stecken
wir Google da rein und das ist ein
kleiner Luftballon der Luftballon muss
natürlich rosa sein deswegen nehmen wir
noch ein rosa Filzstift und meine
einfach rosa dass ich dieses mal nicht
so viel über die Serie spreche ich habe
in meinem letzten Video wo ich mich zu
wenn es umgestalt hat und sehr viel
darüber gesprochen deswegen hatte ich
das Gefühl jetzt dass ich alles Wichtige
eigentlich schon gesagt habe
jetzt schauen wir mal unseren
Körper die Idee ist jetzt
zack ich glaube ich muss so ein
Schaschlikspieß oder so reinpacken und
dann steht da so hier und dann würde ich
ihn erst modellieren glaube ich obwohl
wenn ich vorsichtig bin nee lieber nicht
auf der Toten Hose wir haben jetzt noch
schwarzes Fondant Fondant von dort übrig
und daraus machen wir jetzt seinen
Umhang und ich merke das zu klein
geraten deswegen brauche ich jetzt
erstmal meinen Kopf ja und dann ist es
eigentlich ganz einfach der braucht
jetzt erstmal nur ich sag das auch so
als ob ich eine Ahnung hätte wie das
jetzt hier endet okay
ich habe das jetzt hier unten ein
bisschen kaputt gemacht aber ich glaube
das ist gar nicht so schlimm das passt
auch zum Look von so einem Sensemann ne
aber ich finde es okay und so einfach
macht man
das gar nicht schlecht ich habe jetzt
ein bisschen quetscht der kommt jetzt so
auf den Kuchen ich sag mal so Vanessa
die bäckermeisterin ist wieder da
ja
Gary face haben und noch ein bisschen
Umhang zu moderieren
[Musik]
ja ich nehme das so oh mein Gott das ist
immer so furchtbar wenn sowas so lange
dauert aber dann wenn man es fast
geschafft hat
jetzt kommt die letzte Kirsche auf dem
Eisbecher wir schreiben happy sixteen
birthday
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
so Leute ich kann es einfach nicht
fassen dass sie in der Serie diese Torte
nicht gegessen haben der Junge muss so
lange dran gebacken haben so viel Mühe
reingesteckt haben und dann haben sie
die nicht mal probiert aber das machen
wir dafür heute und nun stellen wir uns
der allerwichtigsten Frage wie schmeckt
die Torte die Wednesday zu ihrem 16
Geburtstag bekommen hat
mich anschnallen das ist immer das
schlimmste Moment
sieht nicht schlecht aus oder Timo man
versteht doch dass es schwarz-weiße
Streifen sein soll ne so wie Wednesdays
Style sind wir bereit fürs probieren
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
das schmeckt viele Milchschnitte Torte
richtig geile Milchschnitten Torte am
Ende des Tages muss man wieder Props an
Sally geben weil das ist einfach ein
bisschen tortenwelt Rezept aber ich
hätte niemals gedacht dass diese dunkle
Ganache funktioniert weil als sie sie
zubereitet habe das alles andere aussah
als lecker ich habe die Böden bisschen
verkackt weil die nicht alle gleich groß
sind aber ansonsten
macht sie bloß nicht nach weil es dauert
ewig von dieser blöde Sensemann den man
sogar essen kann also da drin sind weiß
Crispies ich habe hier ein bisschen
schräg reingeschnitten das waren ganz
schön dummer Fehler aber das sieht schon
ganz schön gut aus tschüss ich hoffe
euch gefällt ähm ja und ja Tschüss Ende